in paris protesters and police have
clashed during a march against france's
so-called health pass
the pass requires proof of vaccination
against covet 19
or a negative test to enter many public
venues
and lawmakers are now debating making it
even stricter
in the hope that it'll persuade more
people to get the jab
but the demonstrators say the measures
breached their civil liberties
shrouded in clouds of tear gas the city
of light dissolved
into a battleground as police and
protesters clashed
over proposed covet 19 restrictions
rallies were held across paris on
saturday against a bill being debated by
lawmakers which passed its first reading
the day before
the new measures would require everyone
in france
to have a special virus pass to go to
restaurants and other venues
it would also make vaccinations
compulsory for healthcare workers
i'm absolutely against it because i'm
not vaccinated
on september the 15th if i'm not
vaccinated i will lose my job
i have been threatened with the sack i'm
here today in favor of the freedom to
choose to get vaccinated or not
we need to wait a little bit before the
french people can decide
i feel that we are being rushed it's
only been six months since these
vaccines were made widely available
and it feels like french people are
being forced i think a part of france is
always going to be unwilling
kovic 19 infections are spiking once
more across france
and hospital admissions are also on the
increase
the government has responded by speeding
up its vaccination campaign
to protect the most vulnerable and also
avoid
fresh lockdowns despite the threat of
water cannon
these protesters at least refused to
back down
against the proposal for a nationwide
coronavirus pass